con velas y pancartas hacen un llamado a
la paz una vigilia en protesta por la
violencia policial luego de que el
jueves equipos tácticos de policías y
militares realizarán una redada en una
de las favelas del complejo alemao en
río de janeiro la incursión policial
dejó 18 muertos que según un comunicado
de las autoridades eran líderes de
presuntas bandas criminales sin embargo
la comunidad asegura que el uso de la
fuerza es excesivo y que los ciudadanos
son víctimas de la recurrente violencia
policial
y
la violencia más grande que existe es la
del estado contra nosotros la falta de
trabajo la falta de escolarización la
falta de proyectos sociales la falta de
alimentación para nuestras familias si
das trabajo la gente tendrá dignidad si
un niño ahora tiene un rifle en la mano
es porque desde 2010 el gobierno no le
ha dado la oportunidad de hacer algún
deporte o tomar cursos para convertirse
en un profesional
alemao es un complejo de 13 favelas
ubicado al norte de río de janeiro con
al menos 70 mil habitantes allí la
policía de río ha utilizado helicópteros
para disparar a objetivos y seguro
ciudadanos los disparos incluso han
llegado a zonas residenciales con el
objetivo de reducir los asesinatos
policiales y evitar violaciones de
derechos humanos el tribunal supremo de
brasil estableció en el primer trimestre
de este año una serie de condiciones
para que la policía realizará redadas en
las favelas ordenando que la fuerza
letal se utilizará sólo como última
instancia luego de agotar todos los
demás medios o cuando fuera necesario
para proteger la vida sin embargo el
presidente ya ayer bolsonaro ha apoyado
públicamente la mano dura contra el
crimen organizado y ha asegurado que los
mafiosos deberían morir como cucarachas